Thanks and now we're gonna spend the
next hour asking you about Jon Snow
that's cool right
no I know that you can't give anything
away from season six really so what we
want to ask you or some behind the
scenes questions essentially can you
give us an idea of what life is like on
the set weeks we want to know who's the
practical joke or who's the guy that
can't get out of character Joker I think
probably David and Dan are the biggest
practical jokers on set yeah I think all
the actors are too too scared for their
for their lives to actually like make
any jokes
yeah the creators of the show is there
anyone that stays in character that's
completely method the whole time the
Dragons yeah they're really hard to have
a conversation with that completely
method and who's the one person that
sort of always breaks character that
can't help but get the giggles sometimes
he shy know that you're a huge fan of
the show and you read the books who else
on set is the biggest superfan would you
say read all the books constantly bugs
george RR martin i'd say well it's funny
because we're like the story line that
i'm minutes are were all kind of new so
we all kind of had the same excitable
energy jeez he knows who plays like my
Marius and she her and I on the first
kind a couple of weeks like couldn't
breathe like when we're on see it like
it was it was like we'd felt like we've
won the golden ticket so if it hasn't it
hasn't dissipated at all though like I
still get very excited about it I'm
trying to think yeah I don't really know
I was always the question and who are
those super super fans of the super fans
the super fans who are endless remember
when Pedro came to set in season four he
was such a huge fan of the Game of
Thrones beforehand yeah his first day
he's just geeking out that like you know
he was sitting amongst Cersei and
Marjorie and Tywin and all that kind of
stuff so yeah he's super sweet
we dove Pedro yeah and he's great on
narcos as well I don't know who seen
narcos but it's fantastic
so speaking of super fans you have we
have a lot how has life changed for you
do you get recognized everywhere is it
weird is it
have you had the me do we do conventions
sorry we do convention yeah we didn't do
conventions with I don't know like it's
nice to kind of work on something which
so many people are so passionate about
you can start up conversations with
people easier you know it's there's a
mutual grounds of kind of admiration
respect for the material so but yeah for
me personally there's not many big
changes I still go to the shops in my
pajamas yeah I still eat microwave meals
out of the tin like you know just in a
very successful TV show which is
wonderful and Load is really shared this
is like a lot of cast members so you
know like it's it's there's something
very nice about there it's really
interesting I mean probably get
recognized at least once a day
right sometimes as much as five times a
day like people approach you it's really
interesting being in different countries
because different cultures approach you
in different ways when we were in Spain
it's like the Spanish or like right
they're very passionate straightaway
whereas in the UK people are just like
quickly like slightly take pictures of
you but not even make eye contact with
you they're too afraid to even get in
your personal space but they're like
British we're very repressed and the
Americans just seem cool like the
American New Yorkers are cool so this is
the point when we say we like American
fans the best
you know there are American creators of
the show so yeah um what was meeting
george RR martin like for you the first
time that's a good question
he was really friendly I remember
actually it was in Ireland and it was it
was in this little tiny convention and
this was before the show it even
it was during its first stages of
filming and there must have been about I
think 20 people at this convention and
it was amazing like he was just sat
there and he was talking to some of the
fans and some of the actors that gone
down too and he was just really happy
like he laughed a lot he was just really
engaging wait to hear all about thoughts
on the characters and such so yeah
nothing like what you did in the books
he's a really cool guy a couple of years
ago I was having a conversation with him
at the San Diego Comic Con which I'm
sure if you've you been at right and he
was talking about the early days cuz he
went to San Diego when it was really you
know he's that old he was like trailing
the stores for like artwork and comics
when he was a younger man and I think he
kind of misses that he can't just stroll
around anymore and he looks so
distinctive with the cap and the
suspenders that I think there's a little
part of him that it's just pure geek and
he kind of misses just being able to
walk around emerging but I was like you
could probably do it and pretend that
you're someone dressed as RR martin get
away with it no I'm not really because
the shoots in so many different
locations is there anyone that you
actually haven't met in real life that's
a big we just met lots of you kind of I
mean you cross over a lot and so you
meet people in passing like in hotel
lobbies and you kind of have bit like oh
hey we're working on the same thing but
it's just a bunch of people I haven't I
wouldn't have me I don't think right but
there's so many to like go through in
your mind I know as well it's like I'm
like number 78 on the counselors
yeah is there anyone that you hope to
work with that you haven't yet
Nataly fear nicely infirm I was I was at
an open question fall and I'm Jon Snow
Jon Snow Oh we brought it back great
well he's dead he's dead so you couldn't
possibly work with him anymore
yeah he's got his Eon alright moving
away from John so how about if you could
trade roles with somebody else on the
show for one day could be male female
anyone I would really like to be Rory
I'd love to be the Hound
for a day because he just doesn't give a
flying he's really happy being the bad
guy but he's the good guy he's the bad
guy with the good home good ha he's a
heart of gold so he's like the
antithesis of Marjorie because
Marjorie's doing all that smiling all
the time so I'd like to play the Hound
for the day and just be badass I just
get to run my sword through a few people
Marjorie's shade is awesome so I mean
Marjorie is a complete badass herself so
what do you think makes Marjorie such a
threat to Circe
what a massive compliment that you think
she's a threat
I do ah oh god I love working with Lena
so much she's so cool
why is she a threat because because
Marjorie is trying to be Circe she's
trying to be the mother of the king so I
mean she wants to have a child that is
going to end up on the Iron Throne
so she's as talented as the Masha
nation's and the politics and the
backstabbing as Cersei is and Cersei
knows that so that's why they're like
it's like the Cold War mutually assured
destruction but you know it's gotten
really interesting last season so
they've got new problems exactly my
enemy's enemy is my friend maybe I mean
you know you don't know what's gonna
happen and that's the beauty of Thrones
you know well why do you think Margaery
would be good on the Iron Throne you
said that she knows and she had PR she's
good at PR um and that's something that
Cersei has never sort of tried to do
appeal to the masses yeah exactly I I
don't think the Margaery I genuinely
don't think Margaery wants to be on the
Iron Throne
I think Margaery wants to be that is a
dangerous place to be I genuinely think
Margaery wants to be the power behind
the throne she wants to you know marry a
king be at the third one and I mean
she's losing husbands right left and
center and you know have a have a baby
and then be like Cersei and be the power
it's safer to be the power behind the
throne than on the throne right Finn
when we left off last season you were in
jail as well for homosexuality should we
be worried about sir Loras at all yeah
definitely I mean he's in the hands of
some very nasty people and he's yeah
they don't really agree with him so yeah
he worried have you heard from the LGBTQ
community at all about your character
they've embraced you I mean yeah it
convinced
I always get people coming up and saying
they're really thankful that gay people
are being represented in in a mainstream
television and representatives so well
so that's really nice but I kind of
think in a lot of TV shows now the gay
community are being you know represented
pretty fairly so I think it's great
century I mean come on Jesus
we still worrying about who loves who
come on there's bigger problems
way bigger problems yeah what's the
hardest scene been for you to watch this
this entire show I mean there's last
season it was Shireen and you know
obviously the red wedding had been one
scene that you were just like oh I can't
it's hard Pedro dying yeah Pedro dying
was devastating I was I found out that I
was playing Obara the day that that
episode aired and I don't know if that
was like pre orchestrated but I had
really intense emotional reaction to it
and obviously when you kind of come on
board the show you can't tell anyone
anything and so no one knew and my
roommate at the time was just like dude
it's just a TV show like why you so
that's my dad and that fight is so
amazing right readable it's such an
amazing well choreograph I and Pedro
like almost refused to let his stunt
double do hardly any of it like he he
practiced that fight again and again and
again and again and he did so much of
that she's sad a role so like when we
were watching when you watch that scene
and you know how much effort he put into
it only to be
and Obara is a great fighter as well how
often did you or how far long did you
have to Train I did really similar
training that Pedro done like in the
martial art of wushu and and I watched
that Pedro fight like I know it so well
because I would watch it every single
day we trained for a really long time we
didn't shoot till quite late in the
season late in the shooting season last
year so I think we had maybe like five
and a half months of working together a
big I mean a big part of like the sands
next choreography is the fact that they
don't fight individually they you know
they fight as a unit which brings a
whole bunch of scary elements you know
when you're dealing with three different
people in three different sets of
weapons and so one of the biggest things
was with like no marios bullwhip like I
don't know if anyone's heard of bullwhip
crack but it's really really loud and
like very aggressive and so a big part
of it is that we would be in the stunt
tent and Belfast and she would just
stand in the corner like fire cracking
the whip while we trained so that it got
to a point where Rosabelle and I
wouldn't jump when the when the whip
made the sound so because that wouldn't
look very tough bringing it back to
Oberon if there's one character that you
could resurrect who would that be
oh my god everyone has an opinion all
right hold on all right on three I want
everyone to shout out who they want to
bring back all right
three two one I could just hear this guy
the same Ned so I guess yeah consensus
seems to be man personally I'd like to
see a Catelyn Stark come back I thought
Michelle did a fantastic job it's
incredible I think the show's really
missing a real like motherly caring
character she not so kids but kind of
baby like in a slightly wrong way like I
did yeah I'd like to see Michelle come
back okay spoilers without actually
getting into trouble is there anything
you can tell us about your characters
from the next season I'm back you're
back yes nothing nothing okay well did
you have what's it like I'm set and
between takes you guys sit around and
hang out and people retreat back to
their trailers that was kind of children
we don't go back to our trailers we all
hang your home yeah yeah yeah it's
lovely it's really nice it's like we
just chilled I just read books just talk
about what people have been up to Ben is
a voracious reader he reads everything
yeah all right well we'd like to open it
up to a couple questions so whoever in
the audience has questions for there's a
microphone here here let's see they're
down here you would you like to go ahead
get cozy these chairs are much more
comfortable than the ones popsie swap it
out okay well my name is Ali and ila hi
I'm sue my question is and I don't know
if this is actually Oh over here I don't
know if this actually you have an answer
for this but I noticed at the end of the
last season with Jon Snow and I'm not
going into Jon Snow
like with his whatever he is the rest of
the storylines are all very female
thanks is that something that was
intentional or is this I don't know if
you guys actually know this but it's
just something that I noticed it was
very I think it's an interesting point
there are many strong characters in
throws the moment most of which are at
the that kind of the helm of the
individual plot lines I think it's a
great contestant to the show that
actually it's you know it's not
misogynistic as a few people have said
and actually it has a lot of really
really strong good female characters
which they just aren't really in a lot
of TV shows these days I think it's
interesting I think it's really
interesting maybe it maybe a woman will
sit the Iron Throne absolutely yeah
although personally I think the Iron
Throne isn't gonna be there in the end I
think it's gonna be dissolved like my
theory is that you know the Valyrian
steel kills the White Walkers they're
gonna have to dissolve the Iron Throne
to beat the threat and then they're like
wow we've got no one's in power anymore
and then so do you guys have series of
your own obviously around and oh yeah
and talk about what could happen next
yeah okay we've got a question over here
this questions for Natalie I love what
you do in elementary with Moriarty
and I was wondering if there was a
possibility that he have a brother that
you have a brother on the show who might
play give the actor from another
Sherlock series to team up together is
you and like brother and sister Moriarty
versus Sherlock and Watson you want to
bring a morality from one of the other
Sherlock
no I want you to have a brother who
plays Sherlock already in a BBC version
of Sherlock and have him be Moriarty
with you as a team it to go against them
I read is a woman need a man's help
sorry
point Natalie that was cruel of me no
but I have to say that Rob Doherty did
one of the most interesting things that
had been done with the Sherlock the
original Arthur Conan Doyle storylines
in making Moriarty a woman because I
think we all know the line between love
and hate is very thin so if you're going
to have a nemesis then why not make it
someone that you were a soul mate with
first I thought it was a really
interesting twist to be perfectly honest
and a lot of great names have played
Moriarty from Laurence Olivier's like
Orson Welles I think and like some great
actors so to be the first female to play
the role and I don't get to play it I
wish I was in New York doing it more
often guys I love this city and I love
the role I really know I have some
responsibilities elsewhere at the moment
you never know how long those are gonna
last so um you know I'll be back playing
Moriarty as soon as I damn well can I
promise
thank you okay down here
the costume is there a costume that you
kind of anything like that or like
somebody else's costume like Tyros are
really lucky we have like some great
costumes gorgeous yeah we've got ya as
our really amazing I don't know like how
often I'd wear my armor but if I could
keep it like I absolutely would rock it
I'd like to keep my own my green
training armor
there's something about yeah it wasn't
used that often but it's a really
beautiful piece the guys look so
handsome in their that you always look
so handsome in your like doublet yeah
reporter length cut and men
this is kind of sexy although although
the tie rollers don't get much in terms
of costume this season gel meets we
haven't got our finders are they heavy
those gowns that you have to wear no
well it would surprise you to know the
Margaery Tyrell costumes were not
normally heavy there's so much of them
okay I am something I've always been
curious about is how many of the cast
members have actually read the books and
of those what are the reactions to how
different the show has become from the
books original storyline I can't I can't
tell you how many people's because that
would be weirded me if I knew that but I
get on the state survey like excuse me I
needed to I've read the books I love the
books I think they're fantastic pieces
of writing I love the television show I
think the show is doing a fantastic job
adapting it into a TV show and making it
more streamlined and more focused and I
think all the changes that have been
made a really strong changes that make
for a much more concise and impactful
television show so I see them both as
kind of put things out there yeah I'm
very intrigued just kind of see after
now that we're on par yeah you know like
you know it's we now it's really
interesting now it's now none of us know
you know all of us it's much more
terrifying when you get the script each
week or however often they give it to
you or do you sort of open it with
trepidation wondering go through and see
if how many episodes look to the last
page okay down here to the left yeah
this would be four finale since we came
into play before she became they always
dark you up to the max on one second now
in prison it's now the complete opposite
what a hard change for what you to go
from the dog up to fresh we always look
fabulous we may be in a sack we may not
wash for six days but we still look hot
and said I prefer God I like both it's
easier not being dolled up because
especially as an actress and I'm sure
Keisha can back me up here there is a
pressure to be looking beautiful and
looking great
where is to actually just concentrate on
the acting and this character and being
looking really rough it's quite
liberating yeah I've done it a couple of
times and I just finished a horror movie
where by the end of it I look pretty
bloody rough and that was just really
liberating just not to have to worry
about not not to like Neal ahead say I'm
not worrying
I meant to look good yeah so for a woman
I don't know if it's the same for a man
I think it's the same for guys as well I
think guys especially these days have to
doll up as much as girls do oh yes I
think there is definitely more pressure
on girls but still for guys like there
is a you know there's a certain
aesthetic that you need to look like
which it's like we just like act and be
the characters and I have to worry about
buddy here you know mm-hmm so yeah it is
really nice just to let it all go and
just kind of play hang out you know
about that babe we do that a lot for
used to that I just - first of all
expressed admiration for the fact that
you and your fellows bring such you know
joy to the rest of our lives
after hike
through high use of your craft and you
know dying as often it's not but as
somebody who's been reading the books
for years and having had the books
around for years I have a little bit of
I guess I'd say frustration that we've
kind of caught up and we're still
waiting for the novels to be coming and
having that direct our expectations and
the like and now that we're pretty much
even and if not getting ahead a little
bit in a series I'm wondering how you
guys feel about that excited scared
geeky I'm I'm super nerdy about the
story in the books and just even trying
to think about what happens after this
it's like it's what we talked about and
set most of the time it's what everyone
kind of - everyone kind of puts all the
little pieces of knowledge together
anyone's constantly trying to crack the
code on mass and David and Dan are just
very clever and you know they people
they're the perfect people they have to
be delivering the story and something
exactly right hands with them but you
think you know where it's going like
your character oh yeah
you ever try to get Dan and David drunk
and OH secret are really good actually
they've got a very high alcohol
tolerance exactly I guess also be drunk
they don't tell you but you guys
just didn't stop okay question down here
hi first off obviously everyone here
loves the show you guys are awesome
but you guys have been just so many
location so many different places what
do you think is your favorite story from
all these different places you guys have
been I was a scripted story owning like
location know like location wise oh that
oh well I well I'm really lucky cuz
Dawn's like really hot and nice and so
we get to shoot in Spain it was really
it was pretty incredible it's easy to
wake up and go to work everyday when
you're in Seville that's for sure
Croatia is really nice - yeah Rob Nick
is fantastic like the places we stay
it's right on the sea and it's like an
old town so you can really like feel the
history of the whole town and it's it's
amazing isn't it Belfast is lovely of
course is great - we
not history little right there's a lot
of rains but there are really really
good people
yeah good pubs yeah we got hold up Finn
and I in our first season we worked
together there was like a storm I think
was crossing from you guys it come
across the Atlantic and so it canceled
shooting for the day there was nowhere
else to go because we were in the middle
of nowhere
so it was Geffen Anthony Finn
Gwendoline Christie myself and we
literally sat in front of the fire
drinking wine we really bonded that yeah
that was wonderful
that was that was during season two I
remember and it was apnea rittany Remy
Renly's encampment salami was up in the
northern of Ireland and we were right on
the coast and there was this there was
actually hurricane that came in and
there was an extras tent that was
holding about a thousand extras and
while all the extras were out of the
tent working this hurricane came in and
literally took this huge tent up into
the air and we had to cancel filming I
think it was crazy
just remember that stop talking and
gonna be sued hi so I'm me and my mom
are huge fans of the show and like we
went to like Croatia old are you I'm 14
right on and we went to Dubrovnik and we
didn't like the game of thrones tours
and stuff like that we saw the spots and
then I noticed like all the other places
you've visited too and traveled and I
wanted to know what's been your favorite
favorite place to travel and what place
would you want to also film at I was
really upset that I never got to go to
Iceland because it's so beautiful up
there and the Northern Lights the aurora
borealis are um it's really funny
because John Bradley who plays Sam well
he's like yeah
because you've seen them so many time
you know who's like you know imagine
John's life he's like he's over he's
over it um I wanted to get Iceland yeah
Iceland's lovely I would love to get
back to Iceland
I know Croatia is pretty good we but it
pretty good Malaysia Croatia there's so
many places in the world everywhere I
guess thank you Thanks here hi I was
wondering who you wish your character
could meet in the show like if Aria met
Marjorie or if Oprah met Jon Snow like
who do you think would like really turn
around your character
I reckon Laura's could probably try and
turn Jon Snow gay I'd like to see that
happen and also to share like hair tips
as well I teach my anyway else I would I
I've always thought I would love for a
Barrett attainment was I yeah because
she's like she's my she's my favorite
character and just as for purely selfish
reasons cuz Maisy's really awesome to
hang out with so teach each other some
stuff yeah it'd be really cool to see
all those like badass girls together two
of you fighting together would be great
yeah Natalie how about you I miss Sophie
yeah I miss Sansa I do I really great
together yeah I mean I miss her and I I
think Marjory could help us so out well
she's left now but she could have helped
us sort out ramsey yeah that's a drink
this
I think that would have been very quick
when what's your opinion can I get a
selfie yeah right now but no more this
is I mean this is not turning into
really selfie upon okay well well that
is happening we had a question down here
hi so um this question is for Natalie if
Marjorie could bring back one character
to kind of help her and becoming the
power behind the throne who do you think
that'd be and why bring you mean bring
back from the dead or bring back to
King's Landing either to get the power
behind the throne would Marjorie bring
back to King's Landing
yeah all from the dude the power behind
the what's everyone's opinion serious
names of all of the characters you can
bring back I mean I've Oberyn right by
I'd by the Ned Stark suggestion I think
Ned and Marjorie would be yeah over in
yeah characters on with us anymore it's
like
Joffre wouldn't you bring baby laughs
okay right over here my question is for
Natalie and I just want to preface this
by saying you're a fantastic actress
Game of Thrones elementary and so I ask
this question with the utmost respect a
lot of people have noticed you bear an
almost uncanny resemblance to Kermit the
frog's new girlfriend how do you respond
have not seen that okay so um I had
dinner I had dinner with David and Dan
and when I was shooting in when I was
shooting in Spain go be careful I'm not
giving stuff away right now
I had dinner with David and Dan and I
don't know if anyone remembers I think
it might have been season 3 season 4 I'm
walking along the cliffs with Sophie and
I tell her it was with Sansa and I'm
telling her about how I was teased as a
young girl for having a snobby nose like
Marjorie is saying to Sansa you know I'm
not perfect I used to get bullied
because I've got a ski-jump nose and I
phoned and I was having this
conversation with David and Dan because
I phoned David and Dan and I said please
can you but it's the only time I've
asked them to put in a line and I said
please can you put in the line that it
was a piggy nose a pic because I was
bullied at school and I used to get told
I had a piggy nose I got big nostrils my
whole family does it's a burden that we
bear it's a mono so I said and I was
like for my own demons it would be like
sticking two fingers up at the bullies
of my childhood
if Marjorie like you know just just
joking about it so they were like fine
cool and then if you watch the DVDs back
you'll see I'm walking down the stairs
going and I go pop you know and I do the
pig noise and they they were really good
guys they put it in for me so then when
I saw that Kermit's got a new girlfriend
and she looks at you know I was like
maybe I'm a bit responsible for that
like because I'm the one that brought up
the pig subject in the first place
her name's Deniz I was like you know
yeah well my name is that pig I was like
she saw there no offense to anyone here
is Gordon YZ I was yeah so that's my
answer to your question I'd already made
the comparison to my nostrils with a pig
so I mean I can't really argue about it
then I think everyone will agree natalie
is one of the best-looking females in
the world you bullies sorry sorry I
should have sworn that's really bad it's
passionate everyone here I seen Game of
Thrones handle that way down here to the
left
hi so I have like a funny question than
a serious question so my first thing is
I work for Sesame Street as you might
know we're now on HBO so how soon are we
gonna see some sort of collaboration
happening there I'd love to see that but
the mobs have done like a game of
Thrones we always be haven't they
they've done the game of Japan yes
that's a brilliant seeing that on
YouTube look it up it said various you
know none of you guys were on it so we
got to get you guys in it but um okay so
I have a serious question about this
show and I wrote it down so you guys
were talking about some episodes or
scenes that might have been harder to
watch and so did with scenes like the
red wedding did you expect the type of
strong reaction that people gave towards
it and would you expect that scenes
moving forward would be looked at
differently before filmed or censored in
any way not that I think that that's a
good idea but do you think that might
happen
well the scenes get censored like like
the red wedding like kind of like fell
down a little I hope not yeah I hope
they're wrong the thing that was so
horrible about the red wedding is
because there was such pure characters
like the character was so pure of heart
and so late just you know they had so
much justice in them and then the way
they were killed was so
so in your face and so unexpected I
think that's what it was personally when
I watched it because I'd already read
the books I knew it was coming so it
wasn't as impactful if you hadn't read
the books and then sudden you saw like
these wonderful characters just being
mutilated by it's horrible people it's
just it's not so much the it being
graphic but it's who they were you know
about it and to that note since some of
these scenes cause such crazy fan
reaction do you guys ever watch like
scroll through Twitter right after the
show or during the show and sort of see
how people are reacting on social media
yeah sometimes sometimes I'd like to
check it out because I like to watch the
show at the same time everyone else is
and I think that's what's so exciting
about the show because a whole planet
watch is hit at the same time it's so
exciting to kind of see what other
people's reactions are like so yeah I
don't do all the time but it's when I
know there's gonna be a big moment I
definitely like to read like blogs about
how the episodes afterwards and what
people thought about it and people
didn't like about it you know it's a
global conversation I think it's really
exciting and interesting to be a part of
it yeah okay and you can answer as well
when you first get a script and it
requires a nude scene what goes through
your mind like am I gonna do it or use a
stun dump I better get down to the
gym because I know fur for women it's
different than it is for men because if
you do it in a kind of like a dumb movie
just do a regular flash scene then if
you do in something like Game of Thrones
word there's a reason that it's
happening in it like when I'm watching
it I don't view it as nudity I'm like
okay this this is happening so how do
you prepare yourself and like you know
text your parrot the guy don't watch the
theater I think I mean I think across
the ball with any material it's you know
if you're playing like a real person
like you're naked in real life a lot you
know like I've been so so long as it's
it helps the story and it's truthful and
not just gratuitous of course it's like
I
it's you mustn't get in your it's easier
said than done but it's very difficult
to not kind of if you start thinking
like oh they have my primary school
teachers gonna see this then yeah it
gets a little nerve-racking you know
it's you have a job to do and so you
kind of very much just get on with it
and it's I think yeah it depends like it
depends on the work it depends on the
people that you're working with but you
learn like over time to kind of be able
to gauge whether it's a safe environment
or not
yeah and Game of Thrones is safe and
higher yeah absolutely it's you know
I've always felt really comfortable when
I've been naked on Game of Thrones like
you are a lot so you know okay we will
move on to question down here yeah hello
I think ever in this room was pretty
obsessed with Game of Thrones I know I
am but I'm about to attempt my first
marathon some question for Natalie how
do you fit in the long runs right now
with your training and how's that going
with filming so unfortunately I'm not
running the New York Marathon on the 1st
of November anymore oh I know I'm really
upset about it because the promotional
tour for Mockingjay to clashes directly
we're there so it was always a bit of a
pun I was just hoping that the dates
wouldn't clash and they do I will be in
Berlin because our premiere is the next
day so I've deferred my place a year so
hopefully I'll be with you on the
starting line 2016 if you want to run it
again but you should be resting by now
right it's only three we were one more
what a long run mmm you've got three
weeks left right I when I ran the London
Marathon
I left my self I did
do any long runs thanks sorry oh sorry
that wasn't very helpful I'm lentils if
you're bored of pasta lentils a really
good slow-releasing carbohydrate the
night before a nice lentil stew sorry
that sounded so actory right then didn't
hi my questions for Natalie do you think
Marjorie could have done the walk that
Searcy did leaving the prison oh we're
in dangerous territory were for the next
season if I talk to you about that
you've said plenty thank you
okay that we cannot give away so let's
go down here to the left
hello my question is to all of you
yourselves your characters you know
there are a lot of sex scenes in the
show and I was wondering whether you or
your character was interested in having
sex with a different character that you
have it's a really great question I I
don't think I Barros and dressed up and
having sex with anyone to be on earth
may be so pounce maybe just mix up a
little bit I mean is Game of Thrones
after world nothing well it's a question
and lighten it a little bit
are there any couples on the show that
you ship that you hope would get
together it's completely impossible to
people today suggested that a barrel
should end up with brawn and I'd never
thought about that and I was like well
that could that could work
because he loves dawn as well doesn't he
loves me he loves Dornish women he loves
dawn we loved your eyes off they go down
to planky town
and bran
cup of mead okay over here to the right
hello I have two questions one is for
Natalie so you played the tutors right
and you played I believe Anne Boleyn did
you take some yeah great performance by
the way even though was a while did you
take some of bad experience and put it
into Margery because we know that
they're both like very yeah they're very
sweet yeah they're very regal and they
yeah I mean I was worried about playing
Margaery Tyrell because I didn't want to
play a queen that got thrown in jail
again yeah yeah I mean like now maybe
yeah your head cut off though what
happened was I watched the first season
of Game of Thrones and I was absolutely
blown well we I was blown away by it
especially when there died I was
completely hooked and then when I knew
there was an audition I auditioned for
another role in Game of Thrones and I
will never say what that is until the
series is over thirty so I went in for a
character there was not a queen that was
going to get thrown in jail and I didn't
get that role it was given to another
actress and David and Dan came up to me
and basically said we'd really like you
to play Margaery and I was like I feel
I'm worried about that because I feel
like I have done that gig and they said
you're gonna play completely differently
we trust you as an actress that you're
gonna find a different colour and I was
really nervous about it but it's only
you guys it's fans over the year that
have come up to me and said don't worry
you did alright and now when I look back
because I played and for two years and I
played Margaery for five I think of
Anna's fire and I think of Margaery is
cool like ice Song of Ice and Fire
I did that so I they do have different
temperaments they really do and Berlin
wouldn't be able to keep her calm the
way Margaery does no way she'd have
exploded and like been killed like
straightaway other questions for all of
you what are your theories on how it's
and so basically I think there'll be a
huge battle between ice and fire they'll
have different factions
I think the ice and fire will completely
destroyed themselves in this great war
they'll destroy the whole of Westeros
they'll dissolve the Iron Throne because
they have to because they have to use
and then I think a lot of people were
dying and I think out of the ashes will
come like the tree people and I select
few people and they will grow Westeros
anew and give back power to the people
I had dream of dream of spring is that
the last book you know this idea of
regrowth and I think maybe it'll be like
bran Hodor maybe Brienne Tyrion just
like good guys to kind of give peace
back to the realm it's very well thought
out in various but knowing Game of
Thrones really horrible little fingers
on the Iron Throne or something
hi I was wondering if you had any funny
stories from on set or any sort of who's
your favorite person to work with on set
sort of choose one and get in I like
working with them as well played Renly I
I really like working with Jerome Flynn
yeah yeah he's really fantastic he's
very fun and very calm which is nice cuz
it's even though I mean they the
production value is so huge and it's
very cinematic but it's still shot like
television and the sense that you don't
have a lot of time in the day and so it
can feel a little bit like oh I'm
getting it right so it's nice to have
his kind of energy around he's very it's
like one of the most chilled out people
I've ever met there must be a lot of
pressure as an actor to not have many
takes to get the shot right correct cuz
the setup is so and expensive and
intense yeah for sure there's so many I
mean some I mean there's yes and no
because I feel like toes a lot of the
job is done for you because honestly
like you turn up and you're on these
like incredible locations the seats are
amazing you're working with the best of
the best directors and and alongside the
best actors and you it's very easy to
feel like you're a part of the world you
know especially with the costuming and
the you know the way you go oh yeah it's
you there's there are moments for you
like I wouldn't be surprised if a dragon
flew overhead because I'm totally in the
zone so in that scene to be very lucky I
think with you when you portrayed Anne
Boleyn I feel like you always play these
really strong women so I guess my
question is if you could pick someone
like as your ideal role either real or
fictional who would you pick am i oh wow
that's a really tough question if I
could pick any role any role male female
anything that's a really hard question
babe I can't really the thing I love
about being an actor is you never know
what job you're gonna be doing next year
two years time you never know where
you're gonna end up I'm attached to a
film at the moment that I can't tell you
guys about because it's not been
officially announced but I'm attached to
a movie at the moment but that is about
a real life woman who is still alive and
did something really incredibly brave as
far as I'm concerned and I'm really
hoping that that movie gets all its
financed and then it goes next year so
she'd be right up there in my head at
the moment because as an actor you kind
of just thinking about what's in front
of you at any given moment so cinema is
finally catching up with TV and
understanding the
three dimensional three dimensional
fleshed-out women you know the audience
want to see that it's economically
viable commercially viable as well and
so slowly there's more opportunities in
scripts for really these female roles
and Katniss Everdeen is a perfect case
in point of you know a flawed hero but a
female protagonist and I I am note
because because I'm older than these two
and I've been working for longer I've
started to notice a change in the female
roles in scripts in the last handful of
years and I think shows like Game of
Thrones are responsible for that so I'm
really excited about the future down
here if you could bring in a character
from any other TV show into Game of
Thrones who would it be and why I've
just watched mr. robot I don't know the
guy Remy Malick the guy that plays the
guy I'd love to see him on Game of
Thrones I think you could play a really
interesting kind of character
maybe something up at the wall or
something like that super cool good
answer Liam Neeson this guy wants Liam
Neeson my question is for Natalie and
Finn the last time we saw your
characters you were still in jail in the
black cells so my question is if you had
a choice to choose a champion for a for
a trial by combat or who would you pick
myself I'd fight for myself but I think
you can though I do that's against the
rules
it probably is right yeah choose someone
maybe Bronn yeah
and are we gonna see Loras do any more
fighting Oh red I nominate you you're
meant to be the greatest night and yeah
you could be my coach ampion me I'd have
to get out of jail first though you'd
have like so that would be like our loop
that would be the claws okay push him
down here yeah thank you all for coming
I just had a quick question on what you
think Martin's historical influence was
like a specific time period or specific
historical figures that he drew upon for
each character for each character
general well it's a hybrid he knows his
history he knows his British the British
Isles
he knows his Romans he knows his Celts
he knows his War of the Roses
he knows his he knows he knew he knows
the American Civil War he you know he's
read his Tolkien there's also a lot of
like pagan mythology and Nordic
mythology as well yeah it's a it's a
hybrid he's pulled it from everywhere
he's a brainy guy I would love to spend
a day in Mantid like honestly yeah
incredible his thought process it's a
giant library okay we have time for a
few more questions over here yes okay um
I love you guys and I think everyone
loves your characters but I was
wondering if if you could pick one noble
house or a noble family name to be part
of who would you guys pick as
individuals to know more about you you
mean us in real life yeah you and real
life not your Oh stalk without a doubt I
like you even more now oh yeah that's a
no-brainer is intent yeah absolutely
absolutely I for a long time my Twitter
handle was was Keyshia stock and and
when I when I got cast I got a lot of
trouble from HBO
because they were thought that I'd kind
of was giving clues no I'm genuinely
sitting at home thinking about being a
member of the stack family
yeah I don't know I guess I'm at I roll
through and through like I love Tyrells
I wouldn't choose to be a part of any
other house standing yea showing me up
there brother really supportive for your
sister thank you I mean the Starks I
love the start okay down here hello do
you do you all have a favorite or least
favorite moment in your own performances
on the show just quickly become a very
intense therapy session favorite or
worse do you mean both either/or I like
shaving a guy's chest and then giving
him a and you know what you know
what that was my first ever day on set
my father every day I was like boy what
did I just let myself in six years later
finest anybody else have a favorite
scene from the entire season or from the
show you can't top that how do you yeah
where do you go from there question down
here hello my name is Melissa I love the
show um I just wanted to let you know
you can't see but I do have a shirt on
that says Sean Bean why you know survive
if you guys want to selfie with me I'm
in the third row I am blown away by the
fact that telltale games actually got
you guys to do the voice
characterizations for the game of
thrones game I'm blown away by that how
did that come about you guys are so busy
with so many projects that you're in and
yet you're doing the voice
characterizations for a game a video
game it blows me away you guys do a
phenomenal job I think I'm taking credit
for that because I was the first person
to say yes I think I was how did it come
about I was just so fascinated by the
idea that
they were gonna do that it seems such a
huge specification to me and when we do
the sessions they last like three four
hours at a time
like I'd done like because you guys get
to click on it and decide what you're
gonna do so I we read the outcome of
like four or five different for every
sentence so I've done about six seven
sessions up to this point or three four
hours long but it's really interesting
it's so fascinating on it I mean we've
got graphic designers in the room today
I believe because a few people have come
up you know our people that want to be
you know that want to enter into that
world it's such a fascinating um
technical art form to me that I was like
this is curious I really want to do this
I think it's the new way of storytelling
as well like I've not played the new
Metal Gear Solid game but just looking
at like trailer and the way that stories
are not being put across in videogames
is like wow like they're given full
licence for really gnarly story ideas
and there's no it doesn't seem there's
any limits or any restrictions on to
content so I think video games are a
huge interesting kind of platform for
interesting dynamic stories long live
house Forrester yes all right guys we
need to wrap it up so put your hands
together for Finn Jones Keisha castle
Hughes Natalie Dormer and we'll see
everybody in season six of Game of
Thrones where's yours thank you
you